my friends I'm Ilana and as some of you
have noticed this is the first video
that I've made on this channel and like
two three months I don't know it's been
a while
sorry Claudia's not great and the
backgrounds ugly I just really wanted to
get this done and of course the car
alarm goes off right now excellent so
some of you started to notice that I
haven't uploaded in a while I started
getting message to comments about it so
I just wanted to talk about why that
happened it's a very short version of
the story is that I have chronic fatigue
something that I probably had my entire
life wasn't it's not like I was
diagnosed as a baby or anything but it
is a syndrome literally goes by CFS that
means you are extremely tired a lot it's
more complicated than that
like you'll get dizzy I fainted a few
times you get really bad joint aches
basically just existing can be very hard
and I'll get into the specifics of that
in a little bit but towards the end of
last year my chronic fatigue just got
really bad
probably stress-related it's a very hard
thing to diagnose it's very hard for
doctors to figure out why it hit certain
people the way that it does but because
mine was very bad my doctor made me go
see a therapist and they gave me a 10
out of 10 on the stress scale which is
very odd and as a slight sidestep it
strange to me because at no point did I
feel stressed I know that a lot of very
stressful things happen to me in a 12 to
18 month period of time
some of which include moving cities
leaving all my friends in a different
City he's starting a new job but there
was also something that's not it in like
March last year that like I know really
messed me up that I just never really
dealt with and just sort of walked away
from my dog died and family was cancer
and just some stuff that I'm not gonna
talk about but point being bad stuff
just have happening and I just kept
running through it and so I think that
resulted in me being like I don't feel
stress I feel fine
but my brain was still dealing with
everything and that's why the doctors
made me go see a therapist basically it
just builds up so much that I just
couldn't handle it anymore and my
chronic fatigue got very very very bad
pointed to their friends if some
terrible [ __ ] happens to you and you
don't deal with it you just keep running
probably catch up don't do that so what
that meant was that starting in November
probably you might have even been
earlier than that honestly actually just
a whole lot of last year I was
definitely very very very fatigued but
it got really bad something November
December I would try to get up and
sometimes follow them the serious
morning that I had and I didn't tell
many people about this at all I got up
and I eventually fainted and hit my head
and didn't wake up again till 3:00 p.m.
and had full conversations with people
in the morning I called someone I had
text conversations and when I woke up in
the afternoon I had no recollection of
those conversations about happening that
was pretty scary so it's like imagine
laying in bed and I'll still wake up for
my alarms or whatever I'd still be up I
would be awake but the idea of standing
up is just unfathomable
I was scared of walking down my
staircase sometimes because it's like
having a brutal hang of it that's just
centered around a head and and the idea
of standing it felt impossible the whole
body aches your head just is vibrating
almost and even lifting an arm can feel
like the most difficult thing in the
world you just feel so brutally
exhausted from everything all the time
so imagine how like it it's hard to talk
about because a lot of people will be
like oh you're just a person who wants
to sleep in but it's a lot more
oppressive than that and I understand
why it's hard to explain why being
exhausted all the time is so difficult
I was just physically exhausted all the
time I had to stop going in the gym
don't B's me any stuff working out
because the times that I went to the gym
I just often would so just kill me and
the reason that I stopped making videos
aside from again my doctor being like
well what if you didn't work multiple
jobs and you cut that [ __ ] out was
because I started to get just dumped I
would forget things I would say stupid
[ __ ] and then watch it later in a video
and be like what was they talking about
my brain stopped functioning No
it would be very hard for me to keep
track of things my short-term memory got
messed up I would say the wrong name of
a video game when I was thinking of
another one and then again watch it
later and be like what was I doing it's
like everything and your brain is fuzzy
and scrambled and it hurts at the same
time and that's the only one of the
weird parts is that for the most part I
seem fun I come across as funny
oh maybe grown a bit then I was on
painkillers with the joint pain like
aside from being actively exhausted
constantly you wouldn't really know you
would just think that I was just I don't
know
forgetting [ __ ] not noticing stuff it's
just all of these little things that
kind of combine to making you feel like
a shell of yourself but constantly it's
like being hungover constantly that kind
of exhaustion like you've just run a
marathon right so you run a marathon you
Yohan oppa and maybe also kind of high
because you can't remember [ __ ] or like
process information in the same way but
that was the reason I wanted something
video is this because I kept slipping up
and I was aware that I was slipping up
I'm sure it added to the stress as well
for me having that continually produce
content but yeah I instead was spending
more time in bed I was still fine like
talking to people on the phone is still
playing video games
I'm still trying my best to go to social
outings where I would mostly just sit
down but it made you know creating any
kind of engaging content where
especially where it's just me very
difficult I don't wanna say I'm like 100
percent better now but I think I am
doing better I'm a lot better than I
wasn't descent but at the very least so
the things that helped were probably the
therapy talking through the things that
was stressing me out and some of the
traumatic [ __ ] that was going down and a
wall asleep
virtually all I did of the Christmas was
sleep and I need a lot I just started
going back to the gym again
[Music]
meaning healthier as well because for a
while there because I didn't have the
energy to make food I was just eating
trash but it is getting better but I
don't wanna bite off more than I can
chew I don't want to jump right back
into making one video a week here if my
body's not ready for that and then I
would just put myself back in the same
spot that I was in which was really
awful was like being a husk of humidity
with it would be like if you were
depressed without the depression pot
because I wasn't unhappy
I wasn't melancholy I just couldn't
physically do anything and I was
frustrated about it instead because the
fainting pot yeah I had told a few
people but I was worried about the
fainting because I lived by myself and I
was worried that if I passed out one day
and didn't get up that nobody would be
able to get in my apartment no one would
know I would just pass out and I would
stop answering calls and then my phone
would die nobody would know how to get
to me not many people know where I live
that was a scary thing be like what am I
gonna do if I faint and hit my head and
bleed to death or something when I can't
do anything about it and no one would
know and I don't live with anyone I
would just do walked in like a pop oh
that was scary [ __ ] I had you know long
conversations with both my parents about
it being like what should I do about
this this is happening and you guys
aren't here it's a hard thing to deal
with when you're by yourself I'm sure
anyone else who has chronic fatigue
because I know it's not that uncommon
when you have a really bad bout of it
because it's not that all the time
it's just when things happen that lead
to it being brutal it would be a lot
easier to be in hospital or yet to live
with someone all right I think that's
all I have to say basically yeah I was
very sick with a very specific honestly
quite difficult to explain illness that
I know is very hard for people to relate
to because a lot of people when you just
touch on it will be like you're just
lazy and I hate that reaction but also
understand where it comes from because
you seem fine you know aside from
physically being in pain and being
exhausted and everything feeling very
difficult and you've been tired all the
time you seem okay you're not coughing I
looked bad I definitely looked gaunt but
it's really hard for people to relate to
anyone else out there who does chronic
fatigue I'm sure you know what I'm
talking about it sounds like you're just
like no I'd like to nap please no it's
not bad it's not bad